hey guys I'm Ryan Wright and I'm Katie
du Bois we're gonna review the trailer
today for the man from u.n.c.l.e uncle
I'm sure it sounds like it stands for
something
yes I would think so underwear Norwegian
lacrosse no you missed the C [ __ ]
I danced for [ __ ] underwear Norwegian
[ __ ]
then what was used to cry lacrosse
enthusiast what sounds angry
super mad name is he looking at it does
he have just one hand on the steering
wheel
when you hear something that sounds like
a gunshot
right
[Music]
yes
[Music]
we recently discovered the existence of
an international criminal organization
with ties to former neces woman has a
little turn out in Bahamas
they have no choice but to work to give
them to infiltrate this organization
[Music]
Napoleon solo this year is most
effective patience
[Music]
the youngest man to join is no best
within three years America is teaming up
with seems to get a little messy - okay
I'll let you talk
[Music]
I still hope that I won't sometimes just
never when I'm stealing things not very
good at this whole thing
and be like this for 20 minutes
[Music]
the Special Agent John I was having a
very special day
who these belong to you or to me yeah
that was sexy that looks like a hood of
a time that was awesome
I love the throwback vibe they have
going on Oh totally
there were handsome super handsome guys
doing super cool spy moves you had
beautiful women it was thrilling it was
like a classic spy espionage thriller
Avena yeah like but not over Hollywood
if I the production design of it looks
beautiful
the acting style you could tell they
studied how movies were done back then
oh yeah I love how all the actors are on
board for the kind of style of acting
that they're going for here yeah so it
makes the whole world seem that much
more believable the action looks great
so Guy Ritchie who knows how to make fun
movies in it it doesn't look like
typical Guy Ritchie shot you know like
every time I see a guy Richie film they
always kind of look similar but this
looks very different no it's very
stylized oh yeah absolutely
he's good with style I just love the
look that I having that's it
it's got style it's a sexy [ __ ]
trailer and Henry Cavill Cavill I don't
know yeah whatever Superman that dude he
already is gonna have a role where
people are not gonna go oh Superman like
this is a role where he can just be
different yeah you could just diversify
himself now as an actor you know a lot
of people get caught up in that one
superhero image and he was likely to get
there but with this role I really feel
that he can actually just be now an
actor that we accept and not just
Superman fine super sized a super spy
yeah you see he's got that charm kinda
reminds you of Archer but more classy
yeah totally classic archers class scene
is always awesome everything Armie
Hammer as like the Russian partner that
he has that dude that's it's a great
combo it's like what the Lone Ranger
needed because that's who Armie Hammer
played the Lone Ranger and no one liked
it but who he wouldn't be the Lone
Ranger no he wasn't a Lone Ranger either
in the Lone Ranger he had an Indian guy
played memory dead the Ranger gang
the Ranger surplus I mean just that
opening scene a dialogue like this the
way how it has such a rhythm to it she's
like she keeps looking yeah
yes you have one hand on the steering
wheel if you hear gunshots drive and
like the way it was shot looks like the
old school actually looks so fine and
then Nazis that's like the ultimate
villain yeah dude any chance you can get
to kill some Nazis yeah who did they say
was ganging up it was um the US and
Europe who we're partnering yeah yeah
that's cool when the world comes
together peaceful parts of the world
comes wider a group of people each and
every one of you here owes me 100 Nazi
scalps that's not this movie that's in
glory no it still blinks in some way I
like the shadows seems very like
mysterious like they're in the shadows
cuz they're spies I think one thing Guy
Ritchie tends to yeah right like 90% of
the time is putting the right actors
together for really good back in fourth
chemistry you know that Sherlock Holmes
he perfectly cast it Downey jr. and Jim
long and I feel like he did it again
with these two like they look like
they're having a great time together
they don't get along at first but
they're gonna have to and I I like
watching movies that play out like that
anyway guys thanks for informing me that
trailer was out if you're new to this
chanel you can subscribe to the real
rejects so much [ __ ] on here have fun
deciding which we do you want to watch
it's kind of like Netflix eventually
just turn it off as you can decide like
like Russian Roulette awesome I played
with other ones did yeah yeah sounds
terrifying
I've lost that's not that game that's
gotta be a different game no I lost is
Russian roulette
50 bucks right out the window don't be
playin with bullets yeah we're talking
about Russian roulette okay you can
check out Katie's channel three
principles has a lot of fun sketch
comedy on there you can see your trade
aside you just got an intellectual side
today but now you can see er get
creatively funny check that out shout
out so it continues to go to
facebook.com slash the real reject shout
outs lose my breath where you can earn
yourself a shout out my saying something
interesting like hey Katie welcome to
the channel by the way you and I are
gonna have some fun today they were
gonna say something much worse than that
attractive female they get it the worst
on this channel so good luck to you
ain't that right Dan yeah no one talks
about me either but people always
compliment Jerry how come none of the
female subscribers want to talk good
about me I pump it it doesn't really
make a difference but